Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Hélène VERNET
(Musique)
(Voix off) Hé ho, toi, là,
tu fais quoi sur le mur ?
(Acclamations)
(Applaudissements) (Sifflets)
Ouah !
Quelle frayeur !
(Essoufflé) Bon, je vais me remettre
un peu de mes émotions...
Ce genre de situation,
ça m'est arrivé tellement de fois,
de me faire courser, contrôler.
(Soupir)
Ça m'est même arrivé
à New-York - c'était en 1999 -
la Mecque du graffiti, quel honneur !
Sauf qu'on est
en plein Giuliani, le maire.
Tout le monde le connaît,
il a instauré la tolérance zéro.
Donc, je suis dans Manhattan,
une perpendiculaire à Broadway.
La rue est calme.
Un pote, derrière, fait le guet
pour voir si tout se passe bien.
Il y a juste un mec assis sur les marches.
Je sors mes bombes comme d'habitude.
Je commence...
Hop, clé au bras, menottes, insultes.
En fait, le mec assis
était un flic en civil.
(Rires)
Pas de chance !
Il m’emmène au poste, puis au central.
Je suis fiché, photographié
comme un bandit.
Et je me retrouve en cellule
avec une cinquantaine de personnes...
(Soupir)
... une cellule bien dégueulasse,
où on ne peut pas s'allonger,
avec des cafards
qui grouillent en tous sens,
et un unique chiotte au milieu -
bonjour l'intimité !
J'y passerai 30 heures.
Il y a un seul avocat
commis d'office pour tous,
donc c'est la bataille
pour savoir qui va passer.
Et quand vient mon tour, il
m'explique que ça ne va pas être facile,
parce qu'ils n'arrivent pas
à trouver le propriétaire du mur
et qu'aux US, on ne sort pas
tant que le procès n'a pas eu lieu.
Donc, voilà.
Il sent mon désarroi,
et très professionnellement, il prend
sur son temps de pause du midi
pour aller voir le mur
et se rendre compte qu'en fait,
le mur était déjà bien tagué
et plein d'affiches.
Il arrive à négocier avec le procureur
pour que je puisse sortir.
Je m'en sortirai avec
500 dollars d'amende,
et la promesse de ne pas
revenir sur le sol américain.
C'était sans compter sur mon côté têtu,
puisque je reviens en 2006 et 2007 invité
par une galerie pour exposer des toiles,
et en parallèle, j'irais de nouveau
dans la rue exorciser ma peur.
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Je retourne dans la rue mais
cette fois-ci un peu plus intelligemment.
Donc, en fait, tout commence
quand j'ai 16 ans,
en 1989, à la Ravine des Cabris -
bien loin du tumulte
new-yorkais, bien sûr -
un petit village pas encore très urbanisé.
Et je fais...
un magnifique chef-d'œuvre,
sous un pont, que je nomme « Wall ».
Avec le recul...
(Rires)
Ce n'était pas tant le
chef-d'œuvre qui m'intéressait,
c'était surtout de franchir le pas,
le pas de l'illégalité.
Moi qui avais été un adolescent
si sage, si discipliné,
à un moment donné, j'ai passé
une étape supplémentaire.
Je vous rassure, je n'ai volé
ni violé personne,
c'était juste une peinture sur un mur,
rien de très grave au final.
C'est ça qui m'intéressait, et
et je me suis vite rendu compte
que le but pour moi, ce n'était pas
de détruire, détériorer des biens,
mais au contraire de les embellir,
d'apporter de la couleur et de la gaîté.
En fait, tout a commencé avec ce livre.
C'était toujours en 1989.
Ce livre, c'est un peu une bible
pour tout graffeur qui se respecte.
Ça a été le premier livre qui est
sorti sur les graffitis new-yorkais.
À ce moment-là, je fantasme
avec ma petite vie paisible de provincial,
sur les Blade, les Seen, les Quik,
qui traînent dans les dépôts de trains
pour aller peindre des wagons
entiers et braver les interdits.
Donc, je me dis : « Pour faire comme eux,
il va falloir trouver un pseudo,
car à la Ravine des Cabris, si je signe
de mon prénom, je serais vite repéré. »
(Rires)
Donc je tourne, je fais une anagramme
avec mes différentes initiales
de mon nom de famille et de mes
différents prénoms de l'état civil,
et je tombe sur le J, le A, le C, le E,
le « Jace » que vous connaissez,
qui sera repris après
par Patrice comme « Jasse ».
J'en suis là, à ce moment-là.
Ensuite, à 17 ans, le bac en poche,
je monte à la capitale :
Saint-Denis.
(Rires)
Quoi, c'est la capitale !
Un nouveau terrain de jeu s'offre
à moi, et surtout, l'indépendance :
le fait de pouvoir sortir,
rentrer quand je veux,
et à ce moment-là, je sors soit seul,
soit avec mes acolytes de l'époque,
Tosh, Otto, Richie, Pop
avec qui on forme un crew,
et on va glaner à droite à gauche
différents graffs sur les routes.
Mon matériel, je le récupère en allant
faire des décos de magasins, de bars,
donc je n'achète rien.
La belle vie, quoi !
Puis, au bout de deux, trois ans
à écrire mon nom à droite, à gauche,
je commence à ressentir
une certaine lassitude
et je ressens aussi... comment dirais-je ?
J'ai l'impression d'être
un pion parmi d'autres.
Le graffiti explose à La Réunion.
On commence à voir
des peintures un peu partout,
et j'ai l'impression de me mêler
un petit peu à la masse.
L'idée maintenant, c'est de pousser
le jeu un peu plus loin,
repousser les limites, trouver
une identité un peu plus forte,
quelque chose que les gens puissent
reconnaître au premier coup d'œil.
Là, on est en 1992,
et c'est là qu'apparaît le gouzou,
le gouzou que vous connaissez peut-être.
Ça, c'était la période
un peu avant, excusez-moi,
où je me prenais pour un graffeur de métro
mais il n'y avait que des vieux bus.
(Rires)
Voilà, ça, c'est le gouzou.
(Applaudissements)
Ça, c'est le premier officiel.
D'ailleurs, dès le premier, je l'ai
baptisé : « Appelez-nous gouzous. »
Là, je commence un peu
à traîner les rues
et à essayer d'avoir une réflexion
supplémentaire par rapport au support :
non pas utiliser un mur lambda
mais essayer en fait d'interagir
et d'avoir une démarche
un petit peu plus artistique en fait,
et un peu plus de respect par rapport au
support sur lequel j'appose ma peinture.
Puis, en 1993, je pars en métropole
continuer mes études.
Donc, j'ai le DEUG en poche
et je pars en métropole
m'ouvrir à de nouveaux horizons,
partir voyager, faire des rencontres,
partager avec d'autres graffeurs aussi.
Il m'arrive des dizaines
et des centaines d'histoires
que je n'aurai pas le temps
de vous raconter malheureusement ici.
Mais voilà, je continue à vivre.
La monotonie de l'atelier,
je ne la connais pas,
puisque l'atelier, c'est la rue, et chaque
sortie est différente à chaque fois.
Je sors la nuit, le jour,
qu'il vente, qu'il pleuve.
Rien ni personne ne pourra
m'empêcher d'aller m'exprimer.
D'ailleurs, l'armée me rattrape,
puisque j'ai repoussé avec les études,
mais je suis bien obligé de la faire.
Je trouve le moyen de passer
responsable graffiti
dans une association dans le civil,
donc, je m'en sors comme ça.
(Rires)
À l'arrachée, j'arrive à avoir ma licence.
Je n'avais pas les mêmes facilités que
les doctorants qui sont passés avant.
Et fier de tout ce succès, je rentre à
La Réunion, le torse bombé, en me disant :
« Ça y est, je vais vivre
de ma peinture à La Réunion. »
C'était un projet un peu ambitieux,
j'ai pris quelques revers,
mais je ne me suis pas découragé.
Et en 2000,
Sophie, de la galerie
l'Arsenic de l'Étang-Salé,
m'accueille dans son lieu
pour faire une exposition
et insiste pour que je monte un dossier
de création auprès de la DRAC.
Bon, j'étais un peu réticent, mais
elle insiste tellement que je le fais.
Et finalement, avec le recul,
ce n'était vraiment pas une bonne idée
parce que d'une, au moment de l'entretien,
ils avaient perdu mon dossier,
et de deux, je me suis fait humilier :
« Tu ne veux quand même pas
qu'on te file de l'argent
pour aller taguer les murs en ville ? »
Je suis reparti la queue entre les jambes,
mais toujours aussi motivé.
Je me suis dit : « OK, je vais leur
prouver que je vaux mieux que ça. »
En 2004, un projet se monte avec
une municipalité dans le sud de la Réunion
qui me donne carte blanche dans la ville.
C'est royal ! Pour tout graffeur,
c'est un rêve de se dire :
« Tu as le champ libre dans la ville. »
Sauf que le rêve a vite
tourné au cauchemar,
puisque dès la première intervention,
un mec est sorti du bâtiment
et a commencé à m'engueuler,
et il m'a sommé d'arrêter.
J'ai essayé d'avoir
l'interlocuteur, il avait disparu.
Tout d'un coup, il était hors département.
De fil en aiguille, trois jours après,
le mur avait été effacé.
J'ai dit : « Il y a un problème.
Je peins depuis des années,
je n'ai jamais été nettoyé,
et le jour où j'ai un papier officiel
m'autorisant à peindre un mur,
on va me l'effacer ! » (Rires)
Il y a quand même un paradoxe !
(Applaudissements)
Ce n'est pas grave, j'abandonne,
et continue à faire ce que j'aime faire.
En 2007, vous devez
certainement vous en souvenir,
Gamède passe par là...
J'ai dû louper quelques photos,
excusez-moi, voilà.
C'était quelques interventions -
hop ! hop ! (Rires)
Très intéressant, voilà.
Voilà, ça doit être celle-ci.
Donc en 2007,
Gamède passe par là et détruit une partie
du pont de la rivière Saint-Étienne,
un gros traumatisme pour
les Réunionnais, moi le premier,
puisque, habitant dans le sud,
on était un petit peu bloqués.
Des travaux se mettent en route.
Et ce pont reste là, figé, sans que
personne ne soit intervenu dessus.
Je me dis : « C'est un bon spot,
je dois faire quelque chose. »
À trois jours de l'inauguration de la
petite route qui passait en contre-bas,
je pars avec un pote avec
les échelles, la peinture, etc.
On part de nuit.
Malheureusement, le site
était encore gardienné.
Mais on arrive à passer
à travers les mailles du filet,
et on fait ce qu'on a à faire
pendant une bonne demi-heure.
Au moment de finir, on passe vite un petit
éclairage pour voir si on n'a rien oublié,
et en tournant la tête, voilà le 4/4
qui fonce sur nous pour nous cueillir.
On lâche tout le matériel
et on se barre dans la rivière.
Il n'arrive pas à nous
récupérer, je perds tout,
mais ce n'est pas très grave au final.
Je reviens quelques jours plus tard.
Je n'avais pas eu le temps de poser
les traces du poulet
qui courait sur ce pont.
(Rires)
Voilà !
En 2009, suite au refus de
la région de me laisser peindre
sur le barrage de contrefort
de la nouvelle route des Tamarins,
j'organise un commando
en fait avec 14 personnes.
On part de nuit, j'achète
pour 2 500 € de matériel.
On a une échelle Anchor,
une perche télescopique,
et on va s'attaquer à un mur
qui fait 70 m de long
sur 20 m de hauteur
pour la partie la plus haute.
On y passera la nuit.
Ça fera grand bruit, un scandale,
à la radio, dans la presse.
Moi, je fais le mort.
Et comme j'avais monté un truc avant
pour demander les autorisations,
forcément la région
est venue me voir,
et m'a envoyé un courrier
me menaçant de porter plainte.
Je vous passe les péripéties.
Finalement, l'histoire s'est bien
terminée, merci à eux.
Quelque temps plus tard,
je reçois un coup de fil :
« Monsieur Jace,
nous allons inaugurer le nouveau pont
de la rivière Saint-Étienne,
et il y a un pylône-test à côté.
C'est bizarre, vous n'avez
encore rien fait dessus. »
(Rires)
OK, là, je ne savais pas trop
quelle attitude adopter...
(Rires)
« Est-ce que ça vous dirait
de vous exprimer dessus ?
- Oui, bien sûr ! »
Je connais peu de monde dans la salle
qui aurait refusé à ma place.
Donc, je fonce et je mène
ce projet à bien.
Il rencontre un certain succès
auprès du public.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)
Fort de ce succès,
on m'a recommandé l'entrée
de Saint-Denis, sur le tunnel du littoral.
Malgré toutes ces commandes officielles,
je tiens toujours à garder cet anonymat -
c'est pour ça que je suis un peu
bizarre avec cet accoutrement -
ce qui me permet toujours
de garder le côté un peu illégal
et de pouvoir continuer
à peindre dans la rue librement.
Et c'est ce qui continue
à me faire vibrer.
Quand je suis à l'extérieur, à l'étranger,
les gens ne connaissent
ni Jace, ni les gouzous,
et je deviens vulnérable
comme je l'étais au début, en fait.
Si je me fais prendre en train de peindre,
je serais quelqu'un de lambda
et on va m'embarquer.
C'est cette adrénaline-là
qui continue à m'intéresser,
qui continue à me faire vibrer
après 25 ans de peinture.
Il y a quelques mois,
je me suis fait arrêter en métropole.
Je ne dis pas que j'aime me
faire arrêter, je vous rassure.
Trois jeunes policiers débarquent,
me voient peindre et me disent :
« Monsieur, qu'est-ce que vous faites ?
Vous faites ça souvent ?
- Ben oui, c'est mon métier. »
(Rires)
Et encore une fois,
ça se termine bien, merci à eux.
Excusez-moi, cette course effrénée
m'a donné vraiment soif.
Dernièrement, vous avez dû
également entendre parler
d'un événement qui a eu lieu dans le sud,
où j'avais mené une action
avec des malentendants -
j'avais participé, ce n'est pas moi
qui l'avais organisée -
pour pouvoir réaliser deux fresques
avec l'autorisation et
la bénédiction de la mairie.
Ils avaient même commandé des
vidéastes pour nous filmer, et tout ça.
Jusque là, tout va bien.
Et puis, j'étais à Madagascar,
on m'envoie un mail, ou je le découvre
sur les réseaux sociaux,
le mur a été tout simplement
effacé par le service anti-tag.
Ils n'ont rien compris !
Encore une fois,
on a l'autorisation et tout,
tous mes autres murs restent en place,
et celui-ci où j'ai l'autorisation...
À la différence de l'autre fois,
je reçois un courrier du responsable
qui tient personnellement à s'excuser,
et qui me dit qu'à l'avenir,
il fera en sorte que son service
puisse différencier
les tags des fresques murales.
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
À croire qu'il y a
une évolution des mentalités !
C'est vrai que maintenant
la presse parle pas mal du graffiti,
ou plutôt du « street art »,
ça fait mieux.
Les galeries et les musées
s'emparent du phénomène.
Les communes et les municipalités
passent des commandes publiques.
C'est tant mieux.
Après, la bataille n'est pas
complètement gagnée.
Aux États-Unis, l'année dernière,
un artiste qui s'appelle Revok,
qui exposait au Musée
d'Art Contemporain de Los Angeles,
s'est fait interpeller en même temps
et a pris six mois de prison.
En France dernièrement, Boris, un Bulgare,
s'est fait également interpeller,
« incitation à la dégradation »,
il a pris quatre mois de prison.
La législation dit que si on vous prend
en train de peindre sur un mur,
ça reste un délit et vous encourez
cinq ans de prison et 75 000 € d'amende.
Dans mon cas,
je vis entre deux espaces de création,
la légalité et le clandestin.
Mais par contre, je constate
que dans la société,
la perception de ce qui est légal
et de ce qui ne l'est pas
a beaucoup évolué et dans le bon sens.
À partir de là, si le gouzou
a pu contribuer à ce processus,
j'en serais heureux.
En tout cas, je suis sûr d'une chose :
si je suis là aujourd'hui,
et si le gouzou connaît un tel succès,
c'est surtout grâce à vous,
le public, et je vous en remercie.
(Applaudissements)